good morning John it's Friday July 2nd
I'm here two weeks from VidCon what's
that
six days I'm sorry to say this but
there's no space in here
for anything except VidCon and I want to
tell you some fascinating tale about
brain chemistry or the peculiarities of
human psychology but John it's not in
there there's nothing in there except
for VidCon I got a big stuff in
there this is a floor plan of the hotel
where I can you can see where the
vendors are going and you feel it close
you can see it all written down in there
so it is my own personal coach he
probably wouldn't be able to decipher it
even if I export in 1080p which I'm
probably not going to I'm sorry that I
have to talk about VidCon because I feel
bad for all the people who are not
coming and I'm sorry to all of you to
talk about this again when obviously you
can't get ticket because it's sold out
so let's try and do something at least a
little bit fun with my one-track mind
right now
let's do VidCon by the numbers 1227 the
number of people who have paid VidCon
registrations - the number of press
interviews that I have done in the last
week one was for the Toronto Globe and
Mail yalter Anton's keep a lookout for
that one the number of local news shows
that I Charlie McDonnell and iJustine
will be on in LA on Tuesday the sixth
tune in to KTLA if you live in LA
otherwise we'll probably just rip it off
the TV and then put it on YouTube 1165
the number of emails that I have
personally sent from the VidCon 2010 at
gmail.com email address that's 1516 the
total number of email threads at the
VidCon 2010 at gmail.com I'm very sorry
- all of those 300 people who I did not
respond to for one reason or another 93
the numbers of speakers and performers
who will be speaking and performing at
VidCon 24 the number of youtube
employees who purchased a ticket to
VidCon 40,000 the number of dollars that
the hotel wanted to charge us to have
wireless internet which is why there is
no wireless internet at VidCon 30 the
number of official VidCon branded flip
cameras that flip is donate
to VidCon to give away as prizes 37 the
number of bulk boxes of granola bars
that we purchased so that people could
have snacks in their tote bags 3 the
number of simultaneous live streams that
we will hopefully be having streaming at
the same time during the entire
conference 50 billion the number of
videos and daily booth posts and tweets
and blog posts and podcasts that I
expect to pour onto the Internet
during those 3 days and finally 15,000
the number of playpen balls we purchased
to have a real live ball pit at VidCon
ok hopefully I did not disappoint you I
only made you excited about how awesome
online video is and despite the fact
that not everyone can be there obviously
what we can be is a really strong and
amazing community despite the fact that
my phone is ringing that makes me think
of another one I just looked it up 250
the number of minutes I was over my
allotted 750 minutes of talking time for
the month of June oh but as I was saying
online video is in the end about online
not in the real world so those of you
who can't come it's ok it'll be on the
internet and for those of you who really
want to come you know maybe maybe maybe
we'll do this again sometime someday
John next time I make a video I will be
in Los Angeles
hopefully having an awesome time already
John I'll see you on Monday